um
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pakman
he is
david pacman
he is
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
1 they think and act like a woman they
are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but whoa whoa
jesse
agree with everything that's raw
abortion they think and act just like a
woman a beta male died but another baby
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and then controlled by the darkness of
david pakman
he is a baby
david packman
he is a baby
[Applause]
david pacman
david patman
he is a male 1
david pacman
he is
[Music]
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming out i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you we're not communicating
you're actually like because you're
asking bizarre questions you're actually
like an idiot
[Music]
that's a progressive vote
[Music]
look at that look at that that
is smarter than you why who thinks he's
smarter than you why he thinks he's
smarter than you
this is just
this one
look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser
alex jones is lying to you that might
come as a shock man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tyranny
[Music]
pac-man's a loser pac-man's a loser
pac-man's a loser pac-man's a loser he's
a disgrace and he's with his christ
and he's with his christ and he's with
his christ look at that look at that
look at that
look at that look at that look at that
look at that
look at that
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now
very very upset with me
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's going to
beat you pac-man never talked to the new
old water because pac-man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
i was telling my children who not to be
it's happening
smarter than you this is
[Music]
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not dave pegman
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you he thinks oh joe rogan
mangoes my bags are mangoes
i love mangoes too nine cents okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't measures
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying from the
mango
[Applause]
[Music]
and highway robbery is what you're do
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we are
following the canadian trucker convoy
honking
romper room for lack of a better term uh
we are live here
in ottawa canada where they are still
going we are monitoring a number of
other feeds of various kinds and we're
going to sort of try to figure out
when are they going to go home
it's increasingly clear that their
demands for the elimination of vaccine
mandates are are not going to happen
so my guess is my guess
is that what we will see is it'll sort
of peter out as number one
some of these people have jobs and
they'll at some point have to get back
to work
and number two you know they're using
sort of like anti-honking and other
elements of ma of of restrictions of
ordinances
to
just like make it not that fun for
people
so
you know i don't know if they're if
they're gonna if they're waiting for
justin trudeau to resign it it may take
a while let's listen in a little bit and
see what's happening trucker and any
person that is uh standing here
taking part
and massive arrests are gonna apparently
happen
uh uh
you can't com i mean
it appears that the document's real
but now they they know that the document
leaked so all right nice nice having you
on here oh interesting so uh they're
gonna start mass arresting is that right
i mean on what uh
on what basis if that's even true this
is the first time hearing of that up
their game i don't know and of course
they're talking about
uh that they might shift and move gears
over to uh toronto but uh these truckers
aren't going anywhere apparently from
what i hear cassidy okay oh i see what
you're saying yeah don't they at some
point like if they're truckers don't you
need to do trucking i guess would be a
question i have apparently happened uh
you can't com i mean
it appears that the documents oh that's
the same this is the audio from the same
feed
it's all very very interesting
um so we're going to be following it
here
and
some people are saying the document is
fake about the mass arrests or not or or
whatever it's not really clear denver
says look at david's eyes that dude is
gone man pac-man's a loser oh the bonus
show or you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad exactly okay um let's uh let
let's just jump right into a lot of
different things here first i do want to
say thank you to some people who very
kindly
uh just signed up via twitch prime those
people are go caps my bag of mangoes do
you grok con queso
jen here and the freak putting us at six
right away at the just just right here
at the top of the stream
um and i very very much appreciate that
i have so many different things to go
over with you guys
one thing that people might like is i
don't know how many of you remember but
on the last stream which was just a
couple days ago we watched this diamond
and silk clip and i pointed out that
the young lady on the right does a lot
of kind of like the hype where she'll
just kind of like pump up the woman on
the left take a listen culture i'm not
for the firing of anyone i'm not for the
suspension of anyone i just want
everyone to have the same even playing
field come on you see what i'm talking
about right so whoopi goldberg was
suspended for two weeks right
because she said something about the
holocaust that was inappropriate
okay so anyway one of our viewers made
me my own hypeboard with i don't know if
is the one on the right diamond or silk
anybody know
guys i know i played the clip last
stream i have something new for you
please
the one on the right is who
nobody knows okay the one on so now i
have a sound board where i can have hype
so i could say guys i want to talk to
you about something very special today
and what i'm going to tell you today is
we have this thing called the membership
program
that's right we have this thing called
the membership program
i'm telling them right now uh and this
membership program
is like nothing anyone has ever seen
and the best thing about the membership
program
is that you can go to join pacman.com
and you can sign up right
and then when you sign up
it's incredible what happens and i
encourage everybody to do so right now
come on david right
so i can have my own sidekick sort of
like hype woman right now
um
and so that thank you to let me make
sure i thank the right person for that
diamond
silk that was um jt
okay so thanks to jt
for getting me those
uh soundboard elements i i think it's
absolutely it's hard to imagine
something better than that right yeah
thank you so much
okay
so we took care of that
laura says via super chat keep it honest
and just the facts absolutely that's
absolutely what we're doing uh let's see
if there's any plan to clear this
roadblock anytime soon child services or
something like that we're gonna get
called and uh they're trying to
intervene
so i did hear that i think that is
factual information too
it appears to be
cheers portland andy yep yep
okay so it's sort of starting to feel
like this whole thing is petering out
but i will see if the if the mass
arrests start here
uh i see people in the chat telling this
stream that david pakman is mocking them
like i'm looking at the chat
on this channel
and there's people going to this guy and
saying david pakman is mocking you this
is travelfun69
i don't think i mocked this guy i'm
mocking the entire event but i'm not
maki i don't even know who this guy is
so i don't know what the deal is with
that uh okay i want to say thank you to
andrew craig andrew just signed up on my
website using the coupon code obama
and you were new member number seven
today also thanks to micro kimmy for the
twitch prime subscription your new
member number eight okay a couple other
things i have actually i kind of want to
hear these interviews hold on let's stay
here for a moment
oh you can't hear a thing
4 400 people in the chat like share
subscribe thank you so much guys
appreciate it
yeah he won't be coming out that's for
sure trudeau definitely not coming out
okay anyway they're not they're not
carrying the universe okay there is a
bit of controversy
um
fellow
uh
host
sam cedar
is considering
extremely serious intellectual property
theft sam who yeah sam cedar is who i'm
talking about
and
he fired a proverbial shot across the
bow a couple days ago
saying that he's considering basically
selling my show as nfts oh no sam cedar
uh listen to what he had to say here's
sam's brilliant idea
monetize his show
copyright does not exist in this world
oh wait a second did i skip it
hold on the right to the ownership of
the majority report would just like but
just the nft of the majority report
yeah
multiple ones we could do we could do
majority ones we could do probably
hassan ones uh we could do uh pacman
nfts we could still have teachers of all
of us
uh monetize his show that's so that's
just like copyright does nothing so
that's pretty aggressive guys if he's
going to start trying to sell my
intellectual property
i will probably have to hire
celebrity lawyer mark garagos to defend
me or i guess i wouldn't wouldn't be a
defense i would be the plaintiff
um
this could be legally actionable
absolutely so we're gonna keep a really
close eye on that and i'm i'm pretty
worked up about the uh possibility diana
says is it true 90 of the truckers are
vaccinated for covet well my
understanding is 90
of canadian truckers are vaccinated
as far as the ones that are at these
events that i don't know what what lance
from the surf tots the surfs told us the
other day
was 90 of truckers are vaccinated my
instinct is that
the subset that is participating in the
so-called freedom convoy
probably has a lower vaccination rate
you do you guys think that that's fair
to to to assess
it's 90 of all truckers
nobody knows okay brian says how can you
mend a broken heart how can a loser ever
win i don't think i have the answers
here for them tristan says david thank
you you have no idea how helpful you are
i'm from the ozarks i watch the right
side media when i watch your show so i'm
prepared excellent
david time to start selling majority
nfts before they get a chance to
absolutely i'm just gonna rape and
pillage the uh intellectual property of
the majority report
hella cool guy says it's because of your
ridiculous big time nft video which was
lame i don't even remember that
video big time nft video
okay well you still love me so that's
good i'm glad no damage was done
i want to say thank you to david davis
for signing up on my website with the
coupon code
there it is
and also thanks to my bag of mangoes joe
sauce as well
for the twitch prime subscriptions
very very exciting
um
all right
you guys want to hear what we've got
going with uh
with right wing platform rumble i was
gonna wait a little bit to talk about
this
but i kind of feel like i should just
talk about it now
so
as many of you know
uh joe rogan
has been offered 100
million
dollars
to move
from spotify over to rumble rumble is
what i would call a trump-affiliated
a trump-affiliated right-wing platform
um
it's not run by trump but it's sort of
like it's trump-affiliated
it's dave rubin affiliated etc and their
big thing is
no censorship
everything goes on rumble and there are
some
oh man i don't want to say left-wing
people
there are some people often associated
with the left whether they are or aren't
left-wing
who have gravitated over to rumble so
for example jimmy dore
has a presence on rumbles
and so what we've decided to do is we
have quietly
made an account on rumble and we are
going to start
uh syncing our content here so from i
set it up so supposedly our youtube
clips are supposed to start showing up
here
and we're going to see if it's allowed
we're going to see if we get banned
we're going to see how much anti-semitic
reaction there is in the comments etc
etc so
you we've set up a redirect
davidpakman.com
rumble r-u-m-b-l-e
that'll take you to this page please
subscribe here and my idea is when when
our clips start showing up here
we want to brigade this stuff now i know
some of you are going to say no no no
i've got to give them my google account
no no you don't
you can sign in with google
you can just make an account you can use
a fake email you don't need to use
google you don't need to use google you
don't need to give them anything okay so
we're just gonna see what happens like
let's see if they kick us out i don't
know let's see if they really are the
the platform of free speech or whatever
and ideally i mean i know i'm asking a
lot here but ideally as our videos start
posting we all need to get in there and
brigade and comment and just try try to
trigger this to show up in like up and
coming or whatever algorithmic element
they have now i see people in the chat
saying we're going to get immediately
banned i don't know why we would get
immediately banned i mean it's official
it's not like
left-wing content's not banned right
it's it's the free speech platform
supposedly
um anyway so we'll see we've got our
first
89 subscribers there right what could we
be banned for as long they say they only
ban for like illegal content or
copyright stuff
um
i i don't know i don't know so anyway
we're on banned for existing exactly
uh david
davidpakman.comrumble and we'll see i
mean it's possible what's possible we'll
be banned before our first clip even
publishes who the hell knows
uh right-wing free speech yes exactly
so
you know yeah i don't i guess uh
i guess i guess we're gonna have to wait
and see
what happens there yeah they could ban
us for our discounts the discounts are
uh are pretty big oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad all right so that's rumble we'll
come back to that
um other things that i have going on
here oh i have a i've had like a list of
videos actually do we want to do some
voicemails first
because i've i haven't gotten a chance
to do voicemails for a while
let me maybe do that and then we'll get
on to the uh
then we'll get on to some of my other
stuff
um okay
super chats here in windsor ontario our
protest blockade is picking up steam
they're trying to block traffic to and
from the ambassador bridge to detroit
okay wow
i can't imagine that's going to be
allowed for very long
why doesn't anyone make a video that is
pro cancel culture it would be more
interesting than everyone agreeing it's
bad is anyone for cancel culture i don't
know
glad to subscribe to your website says
david i hope i don't get audited for
using such a massive discount code i'm
in oregon which is pretty blue so i
think i should be okay yeah the attorney
general of oregon does not seem to be
targeting
our discount codes not not as of right
now
which is uh which is good okay
i'll do a couple of voicemails yes um we
have not heard from whitney for weeks
but she is leaving voicemails every day
i'll play a couple for you
so i have an announcement um related to
economics please so in economics
when people buy something guys by the
way there's nothing more canadian than
hockey being played at the at the convoy
like they've got the road blocked with
the trucks and people are playing hockey
on the road okay sorry let's continue
they
purchase things with
mainly with um their sense of feeling
rather than
um
you know with
uh
like
really
like a good strategy like for the most
part people are like
you know buy stuff because it makes them
feel better
okay here is one from troy york
hi david this is oscar for oh this is
not troy york sorry this is someone else
uh chicago
and uh i got a question
uh i'm over here reading a lot about uh
the tensions with russia and uh ukraine
yeah and i'm wondering what is the
possibility
of putting
like setting out his troops to ukraine
puddin i like that i've never heard
putin called puddin but i like it
and having the u.s fight back which
putin doesn't want and says that if they
do
it's an act of serious consequences
yeah i mean listen i'm not super
interested in these like putin 4d chess
things
because i just have no idea what he's
planning so let's just wait and see
patrick says i follow right-wing loons
on rumble the only account i know of
that got banned was a guy who read from
leviticus the chapter that advocated for
executing gays apparently that's the
line go figure all right well that's not
something i will be advocating for on
rumble
so um i think that will be
um
i think that'll be okay
sorry david parker
i find out the way the
colors
don't call anymore
and it makes the voice of yoda
stay handcuffed
sorry this is my yoda voice
but when a
person calls and you don't want to
just make this voice and they just don't
call back
i'm like you would i'm just sorry
and anyway
oh boy
okay
oh so i also wanted to say um
the
the only therapists that i've ever had
who are actually like really good
therapists
are
um was a was a gay man good for you
whitney that's that's fantastic that
that's really great to hear
uh all right let's see i think i'm gonna
get away from voicemails because it's
become pretty aggressively weaponized
so we're gonna we're gonna get away from
that
um david says i don't think brewer's
right-wing audience genuinely thought he
was funny oh jim brewer they wanted to
laugh because his material was against
what they don't like yeah that there
seems to be something to that for sure
thank you for showing dave ramsey as an
ideologue went to catholic school and an
evangelical teacher had us learn from
him it always felt weird
yeah
uh i would agree with that
i would agree with that very very
strongly okay let's get into some other
things i've had a bunch of different
clips that i've been waiting to go over
with you guys
this is apparently
another one of these entitled anti-mask
freak outs let's see i haven't
pre-screened these
guess what they don't want to do that
either so they cancel their game you
guys need to stand up
oh i guess because this woman lost her
mind and didn't wear a mask she just
refused they canceled the whole thing
and said everybody go home
a principled and defiant speech
globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialist
shun like obama trudeau macron and the
rest of these zio beasts
enough of this this is america
not cuba
she's correctly identified the country
in which the video is filmed i think we
can give her that
very very uh
disturbing stuff god
do you think that like a week later okay
let me let me put it this way we've now
seen dozens of these anti-mask freak
outs
do you what percentage do you think that
10 days later if you ask them they go
yeah i regret that i regret that it was
crazy it's humiliating it's now
memorialized on the internet what
percentage do you think end up feeling
shame
90 one person says no i don't think so
zero percent no i think it's higher than
zero
and it's lower than 90.
wow a lot of people think none now some
of these people end up being ashamed
uh oh there's a good question
christopher says curious to hear your
opinion on the johns hopkins report on
right-wing media is using to fuel anger
and distrust in the government yeah so
there's a report out there that is being
incorrectly described as a report from
johns hopkins medical school or medical
center it's just a report from three
johns hopkins affiliated economists if i
have that correctly and they're like
yeah it's not clear like la anything
works to stem the spread of covid but
correct me if i'm wrong it's not medical
it's not they when they say it from
johns hopkins they want you to think
it's from the medical school but it's
just three economists affiliated with at
some point affiliated with johns hopkins
right is it do i have that right chat
please
somebody bail me out here
somebody says that's probably true okay
yeah i mean
i think that that's what the deal is
hank says the trucker demands are being
uh obliged by alberta and saskatchewan i
thought albert didn't didn't lance tell
us that alberta already had very few
guidelines
let's see
oh no guys
that's so deceptive
alberta and saskatchewan
in the same way that california and new
york and denmark all these places are
just saying we're starting to get to the
point where we can wind down some of
these guidelines that it's completely un
that's a that's such an i don't know if
hank is trolling but to say that the
demands of the truckers have been met
seems bizarre it does not seem to be
what what actually took place
uh people in ottawa are sick of the
truckers
yeah i would be too
i think dems will win the house and lose
the senate says papi okay all right good
all right let's continue with some of
these other videos that we have
anti-mask man-child physically removed
by several people okay here's another
one let's see we can get a little more
zoom there we go
oh
time to
look at this look at this oh boy what
are you doing what the [ __ ] are you
doing oh man what are you doing
is this security
what are you doing is this how you doing
what are you doing do you put your hands
up holy crap
holy crap that's a salt that is assault
oh my god
what are you doing man the guy just
literally forced out uh i i mean it's
was that police
officers do something about that
you know what we can call a 23 cents
wow
you just allow your security to do that
what are
[Music]
oh boy
okay
so that
that happened
um here is republican mesa county clerk
tina peters being arrested
for her very strange involvement in
election related stuff we've followed
tina peters for a while i believe she's
the one that at one point was hiding out
at a house rented by
mike pillow
let's see
she got arrested
[Music]
i doubt she goes
[Music]
[Music]
stop it
so what's going on here is this
mesa county clerk tina peters arrested
by grand junction police for resisting
search warrant
police arrested tina peters at a
restaurant yesterday after she resisted
authorities attempts to seize an ipad
under a search warrant peters was
detained briefly and released at the
scene pending charges
this is apparently not directly related
to state and federal probes into her
alleged involvement in election data
security breaches
nothing else currently available wow
that that is interesting huh
give me my key to my card not exactly a
criminal genius i would say give me my
key to my car
give me my key to my car
[Music]
give me my keys
okay so there is tina peters being
escorted out here is the woman running
against aoc this is uh tina forte
she is now declaring that she will make
aoc a bartender again
how you doing my fellow new yorkers and
my fellow patriots as you know i've been
a freedom i know that okay so
before you even think about talking
about her accent okay
this is not a character that this let's
let's this is just an accent okay guys
we're not gonna comment on that
please fight it for two years i took on
cuomo de blasio now hoechul but i'm
personally taking on aoc sandy the
socialist superstar she's anti-american
she's anti-police and she's anti-freedom
let's fight for our freedoms let's take
the fight right to her like i'm doing go
to tina40 for congress.com and donate
today oh i guess she pronounces her name
40 not
forte promise to not let you down let's
make aoc bartend again let's fire aoc
god bless america and god bless all of
you right
so uh an ominous smile from tina 40. so
that's who's running against aoc
um
let's find a couple of other
recent declarations her test recent
testimony uh here's another one disgrace
and where are the republicans silent as
usual you want to know why because
republicans are justice it sounds like
she's had covet for a year huh swampy
has the demon rap [ __ ] that's
right you're swampy on both [ __ ]
sides right
here's another one oh no this is the one
we just watched can't wait to [ __ ]
debate you if you even have the balls
the balls
so balls that's why i said balls what
are you gonna do oh she used the word
balls watch out if you have the balls to
debate me we can do in our [ __ ]
pay-per-view [ __ ] huh how do you like
that [ __ ] extremely high-level
political discourse fraud fraud fraud
it's a fraud exactly
um
here's uh here's the last one
here she addressed addresses people
criticizing her physical appearance
ready tick tock tick tock my hair color
is naturally messy brown i dye it blonde
and black it's been my signature look
for over 10 years okay sometimes i cut
my hair really short too during race
season
um
did she say during racism what is rape
during racism like is that during a
racist event what did she say
she wears it short during racism
short two during race season is it did
she say rain season
or race season or rave season i don't
even know what she's talking about
sometimes it's short okay
um i don't use botox as i'm allergic to
it i use dysport i don't have what does
she say she uses discord
instead of botox that's interesting lip
phyllis
this in my lip right here is a blood
clot thanks to covert but i will be
having it removed soon so you can wish
me well in the comments this rash that i
don't hide in my neck i don't hide it
cause i don't give a [ __ ] is she from
staten island is that what's going on
that's also from covid okay maybe it's
part of long haulers i don't know i
don't i guess so if she believes kovit's
real at least
yeah bothers you more than me i love
every single one of my tattoos because
they all have a special meaning i have
natural immunity
which is antibodies so no i won't get
the vaccine they're real and they're
spectacular and my voice has been raspy
since i've been a little kid [ __ ] outta
here okay well there we go i would pay
a not insignificant amount of money to
see her debate aoc
that would really be
an incredible incredible incredible
thing to watch it really would i want to
say thank you to daryl fagan who just
signed up at joinpackman.com
and is new member number 12. i really
appreciate everybody who's been signing
up let me tell you right now
we do
need your support i i have to tell you
something guys
there are right-wing media entities
like the daily wire with ben shapiro
who have such
fervent
feverish and fever-rent financial
support okay czech fever on urban
dictionary
that they are getting ready to blow the
left out of the water over the next year
with midterm stuff and why is this this
is because the right takes funding of
stuff like that seriously why do you
think charlie cork's turning paper uh
turning point
turning point usa
uh exists
it's because they go hey this is how you
reach people you got to fund these these
uh uh
non-huge like fox news level things okay
they understand it and the daily wire
has that and the best thing you can do
even and it's also febrile uh even if
it's not this show
we gotta be funding leftwing media i
would love it if you funded this show
you go to joinpakman.com you can use the
coupon code obama
and then you will get access to the
bonus show i can think of no greater
endorsement of the bonus show than the
fact that alex jones hates that it
exists pac-man's a loser
oh the bonus show or you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad exactly if alex
jones doesn't like it
you know it's because it's bad for their
movement okay so i will thank everybody
who signs up on my website
uh today every one of you is getting a
thank you
that i can promise that i can yeah it's
predatory that is a freaking predator
right there okay check out the comment
on the lockdown study by rebecca watson
okay i will do that in my off time david
sir what do you think are the odds of us
truckers joining with canadians and
having a protest of their own could it
be problematic no idea i mean i quite i
don't care what they're doing
uh
that's that's fine they can do that or
not i mean
it's it's all very very strange
david sir loving the stream have you
seen any recent updates from dr mehmet
and his febrile anti-science rantings
let's see if mehmet oz
has issued any new declarations um this
is from december 13th
here's january 13th okay he's
challenging fauci to a debate that
should be interesting the challenge is a
debate
i'm challenging him talk to the doctor
to actually argue about the merits of
vaccine mandates about ignoring
naturally acquired immunity so if you've
actually had the illness why would that
not count as protecting you like it has
for all of known human history and what
about these inexcusable delays with
therapeutics i'm not just talking about
right now although it is a catastrophe
now that we don't have monoclonal
antibodies and any of that it's funny
like
those are made by for-profit big pharma
companies what what does fauci have to
do with that fuchsia's not even involved
in the regulation he's not even at the
fda like maybe also why would you debate
someone who's not running for office and
is soon to retire it's all very strange
what is memit talking about the pills
that we think might work but some of
these pills have been around since
before covet started so what gives how
is it possible that in america which is
four percent of the world population we
have 15 percent of the world deaths yes
that's the question
he stumbles across the key question that
is exactly what what we're trying to
talk about why
well one reason is the vaccination rate
is pathetically low i think dr fauci is
basically the j edgar hoover of public
health oh my god what what a lunatic
okay so there's memit oz
hank says mask mandate is not a vaccine
mandate california ended mass mandates
alberta and saskatchewan ended vaccine
mandates trucker's demand don't call me
sneaky and deceptive still love your
show okay yeah i mean i'll research it
it seems as though it is not at all the
spirit of what is uh of what is taking
place
okay next
governor jb pritzker from illinois
announces they are heading towards
ending
the mask mandate on february 28th if
cases continue down we are on track to
come out on the other side of this
latest coveted storm in better shape
than even the doctors
expected right if these trends continue
and we expect them to
then on monday february 28th we will
lift the indoor mask requirement for the
state of illinois wow we are on track
okay i want to pull you guys about that
okay i'm going to set up a poll on um
i'm going to set up a poll on youtube
and then on twitch and i want to know do
you believe it's time to end indoor mask
mandates i don't have a position on this
i think there's good arguments on both
sides do you believe
i'll just say is it time to end indoor
mask mandates
and the options will be yes
and no uh let's find that out over on
youtube
and then i am also going to do a poll
on twitch how on earth do i do a poll on
twitch
i don't even know
uh let's see is it this thing no it's
not
oh boy how on earth do i do this
channel points
where is the make a poll button anybody
know
pull
only chat no that's not it
slash poll oh okay
okay here we go
is it time to end in order just mandate
yes no
and uh we will run it for i don't know
like two minutes or something like that
okay good all right let's see what
people's um
let's see what people's opinions are
on youtube by a two to one margin
you folks are saying it is not time to
end indoor mask mandates but now it's
less than a two to one margin
over on twitch
by a 70 to 30 margin
you were all saying it is not actually
almost almost three to one now
it is not time to end indoor mask
mandates so people feeling very strongly
youtube is slightly
uh
slightly more
uh anti-mask than twitch
okay that that's fine it's all allowed
um
okay we'll leave that up for a little
bit
uh
tina 40 was spotted at the january sixth
riot how is she allowed to run for
congress i don't know if that's true
that's a good question though if it is
true
i want to say a huge thank you to sherry
hardwick who just signed up on my
website thanks to tracy b who just
signed up using the coupon code obama
also want to say thank you to barbara
webber
and laura potty who just signed up on
the website with the coupon code obama
it is crazy our audience is about 70
men okay
and we will ban men we won't okay the
audience is about 70 men
but during live streams
the new members are overwhelmingly women
it's really something else okay on
youtube by roughly a two to one margin
you guys are saying it is not time to
end indoor mask mandates
and over on twitch
by a roughly three to one margin
twitch viewers
are saying
it is not time to end indoor mask
mandates those are the
those are the positions of my audience
it's what it is
uh have you ever thought about adding a
news an article component on the website
um we have
but we decided not to it's just not you
know one of the things is i want to
focus on our core competencies and we
could very easily throw up like a news
article
element to our wordpress installation i
i just it's there's many other websites
that have news articles i just don't
think it's what we uh
i i
it just didn't seem like the right thing
didn't seem like the right thing okay
let's continue here is joe biden
jokingly talking about windmills causing
cancer obviously a reference to donald
trump uh let me see if i have that
on my sound board
no oh here the noise causes cancer okay
i kind of like that yeah i mean a
reference of course uh of course the
donald trump the noise causes cancer
yeah
um
yeah it actually got a pretty good laugh
i take it back i i liked it i liked it a
lot
have you addressed sam cedar's
intentions to take you down alongside
alex jones of course i have of course
nate says dear mr predatory pacman that
is a freaking predator right there i
signed up on your website i use the code
and now my kids are walking around
repeating this nonsense and alexa turned
us into the nsa the feds are at my door
please send help
okay yeah i can't really help with that
i do want to say thanks to melissa rose
bev
for signing up on my website really
appreciate that also thanks to nug
wrangler
akira loves ryuji as well for the twitch
prime subscriptions
uh okay
all right good
so there's joe biden
um here's a funny one so i don't know
how many of you have been following but
over the last 24 hours right wing media
has become obsessed with the false claim
that joe biden is trying to distribute
crack pipes to black people
that's that's been the big story on fox
news now for like 24 hours
and one of the funniest things is that
congressman
burgess owens or bridges or burgess
owens i guess who's a republican from
utah
he doesn't even understand the talking
point this is sort of like when i was on
with jesse lee peterson and he was
trying to just use right wing talking
points that even he wasn't sure what
they were about like socialism and
different stuff
here burgess owens
said people are being given crack pots
rather than crack pipes
to wake up to news reports
that we have an administration
that for the sake of equity is going to
give black people
access to crack pots
okay uh there are plenty of crackpots in
the republican party for sure
but um
i think that this is just another one of
these confusions to be perfectly frank i
don't i don't think he really even
understands
what on earth he's talking about he just
seems to have no idea no clue whatsoever
what's going on all right let's get to
some of these freedom convoy interviews
i think uh started in the morning a
little bit cold but uh it's a little bit
warmer today
just every day today as we said like
just yesterday we were just talking
saying it's day-to-day uh day by day now
fluid situation yeah yeah yeah you know
a lot a lot of joy happiness other end
is a little bit of tense but uh
everything's still peaceful everything's
still fine and it's just uh you know
we're our eyes on the ground and
we're gonna see whatever happens so i
don't know uh toronto already uh
uh started blocking down the city around
the uh queen's park as they had took
heard word that trucks are going to come
there but haven't heard any information
on that i'm from toronto of course i'll
try to see if i can capture anything
going on down there but other than that
everything is uh peaceful today yep
freed up and that's what it is the good
always wins over the evil man that's how
it is
appreciate it that's awesome this and
this was all
hmm
from a polish community i think you're
saying right so that's awesome they even
organized and even uh bagged up some of
the stuff here and even uh sorted
everything and wrote on the block
this is awesome absolutely yeah
this is this is uh such a wonderful
outreach and uh yeah we see we're seeing
this the whole world's watching there's
uh 4 400 people in the chat right now so
it's quite amazing how many people are
seeing this polish people know what
dictatorship is all about that's the
reason why they came to this country to
escape they're very very big on polish
people here for sure
um so a lot of different things
happening here i mean it's uh it's it's
not clear how long it will go on
presumably a little bit longer i guess
to some degree
but
i i don't know i don't know they
it's it doesn't seem like it's ending
anytime soon i want to say thank you to
iron butt iron butt
just signed up on my website with the
coupon code obama obama and his new
member number 20. also a big shout out
and thank you to i-m-w-r-x-rated
for the twitch prime subscription
uh that really warms my heart to see and
i appreciate it very very much do they
have an open fire going here that's
awesome great so yeah see here there you
have it uh
from the uh polish community in toronto
where i'm from of course
i did all that wonderful donation that
was great
yeah he's a good dude
he's a good dude for sure okay
so they're they're keeping it going
egg woo says i think right wingers are
starting to be starting to be more
outspoken about mandates so that when
they are inevitably dropped they can
take credit what are your thoughts
yeah maybe and it's not even clear to me
that they think that far ahead
uh it's conceivable but i'm not really
sure
sir what's up with madison cawthorne's
election issue in north carolina can you
explain i have not been following it but
my understanding is that the state
legislature is saying they could
uh prevent or block madison cawthorne
from running for reelection and i don't
know what the legal
reality is on that
uh
i i just i'm not sure
so
i'll look into it i haven't covered it
because i i care very little about
madison cawthorne
but uh i i should know what's going on
okay people want a couple more
voicemails i'll do a couple more
um but there's some there's some pretty
wacky stuff ha the voicemail has become
almost unusable
where we now have 900 unlistened to
voicemails it's
like nothing i've ever seen
um let me just pick a couple
random ones here i don't know
hey david uh i just just saw the video
about margaery
complaining that uh kids are being
forced to wear masks
well in her district kids are not forced
to wear masks
yeah that's that's true
jonah says there's a new clip of her
saying the gazpacho police instead of
the gestapo oh i've got to see that
that i have to see
green
gazpacho that sounds unbelievable we
have the dc jail which is the dc gulag
but now we have nancy pelosi's gazpacho
police
that is the best thing i've ever seen
her do
that now for people who don't know
gazpacho is a cold tomato based soup
how is this reality
how is this reality gazpacho
the gazpacho police
no more cold tomato soups
wow
that is unbelievable
not only do we have the dc jail which is
the dc gulag but now we have nancy
pelosi's gazpacho police
oh my god
that is
that is unbelievable
um i've got to send that to myself
because i'll probably want to mention
that
on the show tomorrow the gazpacho police
that's that's incredible
uh
wow
yeah this this is a good one
will marjorie taylor green send out the
borscht patrol next uh don't come after
my borscht my beloved borscht
uh the truckers are giving the industry
a reason to replace them with robots
people are so easily manipulated very
good point
can you press the sur button
let me see if i've got it here
i don't even know what i'm doing sir
sir sir
there you go
um
alberta eased testing and vaccination
rules in september and icu's got so
overrun with covid they had to fly
patients to ontario
uh
wow yeah that sounds that sounds very
bad
david have you ever considered a david
pakman app yeah we've considered it but
i i just am unsure uh we
you know it's really got to be better
than everything else that's available
and uh
the apps for so many of the platforms
we're on are good it just didn't really
feel like an obvious thing to get people
to you
it wasn't clear we would be a good idea
i guess is where i'm where i'm at
thank you to leo grinberg who just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code obama
i do want to announce that on march 1st
it will be the state of the union
address with president joe biden
and we will be live live live
with a pre-show
and the state of the union address and
then your calls potentially afterwards
so that's on tuesday
march 1st
just
three weeks minus a day away
it will all be live all be live and it's
going to be really
it's going to be something
it's going to be something
when can i sign up on your website with
the coupon code guespacho police yeah we
should next we should do a gazpacho
coupon code let me just look at this one
more time not only do we have the dc
jail which is the dc gulag but now we
have nancy pelosi's gazpacho police oh
my god
let me see how people are reacting to my
tweet
uh
it should be called the dc goulash
pronounced
tomato so she can think we're being
pretentious
served ice cold a message all americans
can rally behind yeah wow it is
unbelievable what that woman is is
continuing to say david is the u.s media
picking up reports that of the 418
trucks in the ottawa protest
about a quarter have children living in
the truck is that is that true
it's conceivable that that's true i
don't know
i wouldn't be able to refute it but i
wouldn't be able to
confirm it either
uh all right let's listen to a couple
other voicemails here
david i i saw your um clip today saying
that bernie has no chance he's already
had his time has gone this would be the
third one i would like you to explain
how joe biden ran through it three times
and miraculously one i think that's just
such a miracle could you please get into
the fourth in iowa hiding in his cellar
begging for buff tour money absolutely
broke and then within 72 hours last a
march 2020
uh jim clyburn down in south carolina
declared that fine won the primary he's
the one can you please go over that
because we got robbed wow
caller shot out of a cannon guys listen
it's it's just a difference of opinion
i don't think
bernie
is going to be the nominee in 2024
i i don't think he's gonna run
and i think if he did i don't think he
would he would win that's it's just an
opinion
you know it's almost like people have
gotten really uncomfortable just having
disagreements and sometimes in like the
real world i'll experience this where
someone will
tell me that they haven't like an
opinion and they almost are like
i they have this face like they're
grimacing like
i have an opinion that's different from
what i heard you say on your show
it's completely fine it's it's oh we we
just have a different opinion we it's
like sometimes people disagree about
like what movie is good or what book or
tv show and sometimes politics like if
you know if you're not a hateful person
it's okay we just sometimes have
different opinions i don't think bernie
is going to run and i think if he ran he
wouldn't win here's a caller who has a
different opinion great
great wait it's fine it's not a big deal
david do you have any thoughts on mark
cuban's cost plus drug company seems it
may be an alternative to many inflated
medications from what i know about it i
like it
but i'm sure there would be someone in
my audience who will tell me how i'm
very wrong
thanks to mona kobus
for signing up on my website
joinpacman.com with the coupon code
wow22 also thank you to rhinodactyl
for the twitch prime subscription i
really do appreciate that let me get
back to just a couple of these
voicemails
that i wanted to play for you guys
um let's see what we've got here
okay so one more thing about um donald
trump um
you know saying like that the nazis were
fine i mean when i was growing up like
there was like nazi clubs and it was
like there were just like any other boys
you know like
just people who
[Music]
were like
you know
maybe told
that they were a racist just for
laughing at a joke i don't know yep no
that's all very very important we're
going to look at that very very closely
i've gotten notification that our first
video oh look look at this
we are now on rumble look at this
okay so
let's see what happens if you missed at
the start of the stream
i said we've made an account on rumble
they say they're against censorship
let's see if we get banned okay you can
go to davidpakman.com
rumble we have look at this we have 129
subscribers on rumble our videos are
starting to be synced
um
let's see what happens i've been
notified we got our first comment on oh
no oh my god uh oh
we're getting a lot of comments here
uh oh it's our viewers who are
commenting to create hype oh okay okay
beautiful i'm gonna have to turn off
that i get another email for every
comment
wow that's not gonna work yeah i'm gonna
have to turn that off uh
okay wow
perhaps trump was right on the
weaponization of soup by the gazpacho
police fair point david have you heard
of gary chambers for senate check his
youtube channel the last video yeah he's
the guy who who smoked a marijuana on
video right isn't he the one who smoked
a pot
is that the guy
thanks to snorzy for the twitch prime
subscription appreciate that
um
tyler says congratulations on your
rumble account remember when it's
signing in it may be wise to avoid
signing in with google yes guys i would
just make an account on rumble you can
use a burner email
use whatever pass you know make up a
password
you don't have to sign in with google
and in fact i would recommend not doing
that
i would recommend not doing that
i'm so curious what sort of engagement
we're getting on here let's just if i
let's see if i go to the most recent
video
today i report to you
we are on rumble this one now what are
rumbles is rumble when you hit plus oh
seven rumbles wow look at that
look at that
wow
this is fat we're on rumble let's see if
they ban us
uh okay
let's see here's a plus two rumbles boom
oh justin the dane is really in there on
every one of these videos struggling to
breathe margaery green rants about mask
i'm gonna rumble that
powerful stuff all right well listen
we're gonna follow it and we'll see
we'll just see what we get i think it'll
be really interesting and if we get
banned it's going to be a hell of a
story
if we end if we end up banned it will be
a story that we will cover
is rumble basically bit shoot
uh i think it's bit shoot with money
is that is that a fair way of saying
what rumble is it's bit shoot with money
yeah
okay we i don't know
oh and i've been sent the gazpacho clip
let's see
uh oh people are starting to comment
there too
gazpacho police right the gazpacho
police
incredible
um giovanni stigma says let's set the
bar high
join the stream late hi david with a
very powerful 50 super chat i appreciate
that very much uh yeah i'm gonna have to
turn off i'm getting an email every time
someone comments on rumble that is
obviously not going to work long term
uh
that's that's just not going to work
okay all right thank you everybody
that's all i had for today i appreciate
you joining me i will report to you if i
get banned from rumble i don't know what
their policy is going to be
but uh we will follow it we will do all
of it and i will probably be back
tomorrow afternoon
with a another stream so i'll see
everybody then
you